MANO MARKS: Hi, everyone.
My name is Mano Marks.
I'm the lead developer
advocate on
the Google Maps team.
KURT SCHWEHR: My name
Kurt Scwerhr.
I'm head of ocean engineering.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES: And
I'm Francesc Campoy, the
developer programs engineer
for the Go Team.
MANO MARKS: And we're going to
talk to you today about all
the ships in the world.
So what do I mean by that?
And I'm going to get--
actually, Kurt's going to go
into detail on how we're
collecting data from 75,000
ships and over four million
position reports.
But what I want to do is just
give you a short introduction
to why we're doing this.
We are doing this because, you
may have noticed there are
sensors all over Moscone
right now.
And the team is doing some
really interesting stuff with
sensors in Arduino and just
Cloud and combining a lot of
information.
We were really interested in
taking a look at a real-world
use case where people are
currently broadcasting their
locations and then using
Google's Cloud to aggregate
that information, filter it,
parse it out, and do really
interesting--
see if we can learn interesting
things and
visualize it on a map.
Now you may have seen the talk
this morning at 10:00 by
Brendan Kenny where he went in
depth into using HTML5 plus
Google Maps to do data
visualization using
the same data set.
We're going to talk a little
bit about that.
But you should watch that video
if you haven't had a
chance to watch it.
What I want to do right now is
show you what this actually
looks like.
So the first thing I've got
here, this was the first
implementation of
using this data.
These large amounts of data
from ships' reports.
We took a one-day snapshot and
used the JavaScript Maps API
to load data in from BigQuery
where we were
serving the data out.
I want to just show you
a quick look at
how fast that is.
It's not very fast.
There you go.
So this was a very naive
implementation.
BigQuery was parsing out a large
number of points and
passing it down to
the browser.
But we're going to talk to you
a lot about how we built up a
serving infrastructure over the
last few months to parse
out way more data and
serve it out to you.
This is, by the way, using
straight-up JavaScript Maps
API using our heat map layer.
And then, just to show you where
we're going, this is
what it looks like in Google
Maps using HTML5 and the
canvas layer utility library
to give all the latest
position reports from all the
ships that we have data from.
And you can see here, we've
actually done quite a bit of
work on really interesting
things, including click
notifications, which
is actually kind of
hard to do in WebGL.
And then, you can start to see
really interesting patterns
developing.
Like here, we're actually using
the direction right
here, is the color of the
position location.
So here you can see this strong
red line, this is
people going pretty
much North.
And you can see that
a big path, there.
And just to the right of it--
it might be a little hard to
see on the monitor--
going pretty much due
South, you have
this light blue course.
And you can see that they
actually mirror each other.
And I actually don't know
a lot about ships.
Kurt is the expert on those.
But I can start to discern,
just looking through this
visualization, really
interesting patterns.
And actually start to interact
with the data dynamically.
So, go back to the slides,
because I get really excited
about that stuff and
want to keep going.
So this is the overall structure
of what we're doing.
Ships are broadcasting
their locations.
We are getting information
from satellites and
ground-based receivers that
are picking that up.
That data is being pushed
into Google Cloud.
And then we are doing
stuff to it.
And we're going to talk to you
about what we're doing and how
that actually works.
And then it gets pushed
down to the user.
And we are going to use
all the Clouds.
So this is pretty exciting.
This is another reason we just
were like, oh yeah, we need
this functionality.
Wait, we've got that.
So with that, I'm going to pass
that on to Kurt, who will
talk to you about
gathering data.
KURT SCHWEHR: Thank you, Mano.
So I'm going to give you the
context behind the data that
we're working with.
It's always important to
understand the domain knowledge.
But I want you to remember when
you're looking at the
details here that this isn't
just about ships.
This is about whatever data
you would like that has a
spatial component.
Even if it doesn't, these
tools can help you.
So let's talk about what
is the automatic
identification system.
It's a VHF system that was
designed in the 1990s for
collision avoidance and
to help ships know
who's around them.
It's a public system where
everybody tells everybody
else, hey, my name is so-and-so,
I'm going this way.
And it's basically designed to
make mariners' lives better.
These people out there, these
professional folks working at
sea, have a tough job.
They get pushed around by little
tug boats all the time.
Like you see here, a large ship,
to make it through a
harbor, has to get help
from its buddies.
And if you forget the name of
your tug boat on your port
side and you call the wrong ship
out, you might get pushed
the wrong way.
Those kinds of things are pretty
complicated and ships
have a lot going on.
Now, being that this is a VHF
system, it's a line of sight.
So it means that you can see
out a little ways, maybe 80
kilometers if it's good.
But it doesn't make for great
visualization if you just have
80 kilometers and you're
talking about all the
ships in the world.
It means we really
have a problem.
But we actually have
a solution.
We have some friendly folks at
SpaceQuest and Analyze who
worked with us to create a
demonstration data set that is
from their polar orbiting
satellites.
The satellite's going
around the Earth.
And it's slowly going around,
looking over different regions
and picking up all the
ships below it.
And when you're up in space,
line of sight covers a pretty
good-sized patch of ground.
And if you keep moving, you'll
get the whole globe.
So this is our basic global data
set coverage that we're
using in our example.
We'll get some more
examples in here.
We've got, from the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration, or NOAH, we have
three receivers that are
professionally-installed on
towers in the Massachusetts
area around Boston.
And it's covering the Stellwagen
Bank National
Marine Sanctuary, where they're
protecting white
whales from going extinct.
And this gives you a long
time series demo.
So we have from 2005 to present
in that data set.
It's hundreds of millions
of data points.
And it gives you that long time
series to play with in
terms of demoing.
And to really mix it up, we'd
like to show you what can be
done on the small scale.
We always like to start with
a little test case.
And so here we have a happy
engineer at Google who's just
installed his first AIS receiver
on his desk in the
San Francisco office.
You can make fun of him--
he's having fun in
the front row here.
And we put this receiver up in
the Boston office to show you
that you can get going with
almost no investment.
We bought the cheapest receiver
you can get and we
hooked it up to this
workstation
that was already there.
It's not near a window.
But it works great.
And since we're Google and we've
got to cover the whole
globe, here, we threw another
one in the office in Sydney.
And it has some company with an
Android and a nice gopher
to go with it.
And to show you how cheesy you
can get and still get away
with creating interesting data
sets, they took a TV antenna
aerial, which isn't totally
matched up right, and so I get
a kick out the antenna
here, which isn't
designed for this project.
But we still get some good ship
traffic, because they are
looking out the window
at ships.
So that gives us a data set.
But when we say all the ships
in the world, we really have
to qualify that.
It's most of the ships
in the world.
And I like to show a ship that's
called a Little Toot,
on the left there.
She is a water taxi.
For a $2 ride, you can go out
and see the sea lions or you
ca get dropped of on your ship,
if you're meeting up
with a big ship.
She's too small to be required
to carry AIS.
The larger ships are required.
For something called "the safety
of life at sea," they
have to carry that so that they
can keep coordinating.
The smaller guys, it's up to
them whether or not the ship
wants to get AIS.
But the neat thing is
that, this whole
community has come together.
They realized that this is so
important for everybody that's
smaller ships and smaller
ships are
starting to add this.
And you can see on the right
here, and engineer in New
England who took about an hour
to install this on an oil
spill response boat.
So the data set is getting
more exciting over time.
So it really provides a great
way to look at spatial data.
So what are some of the
challenges with this data set?
Because no data is easy.
And, as I've often heard, real
data has real warts.
So our first challenge
is data size.
We just have a lot of it.
If you put it on your laptop,
your laptop starts smoking,
the fans start going.
And you wait and you wait
and nothing happens.
I've had queries that I've
wanted to do for years.
And it's just been, I don't
want to let my laptop sit
there for two weeks waiting
for it to figure out the
number is 42.
Beyond that, we have
stickier problems,
which is data quality.
We have bad points.
We have ships out there with
GPSs that are non-functional.
You might have heard this
morning about lightning
hitting ships.
We had a ship running around
that kept changing sides in
its report.
It was 10 meters longer, 10
meters shorter, ten meters
longer, ten meters shorter,
all day long.
What's going on?
So we had to call up and say,
you guys OK out there?
Well, last year they got
hit by lightning.
We also have some other
challenges in that when you
have all these coordinated
things like a satellite and a
bunch of receivers onshore, you
might hear the same ship
three or four times.
That's a good thing in that
you're getting good coverage
and making sure that you
don't miss anything.
But you have to sort of cull
that down so that you're only
dealing with one point from each
location and you don't
have this over stacking of data
that you don't need to be
dealing with.
You could make your problem
three or four times harder
than it already is.
So let's talk about--
we've got this data.
Let's talk about bringing it in
and keeping it someplace so
we can actually do something
with it.
Because if we don't collect it,
it's just going to go into
the either and somebody at the
nearest planet or star will
find out about it later on.
That's not any good to us.
So we started off with our
first cloud entity.
We have Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage has got all
kinds of features that are
really helpful for us.
The first one is access
control lists.
If we want to split up our
partners and work with a
couple different groups and we
don't want them to share data
because of particular agreements
or whatever reasons
you've got, we can set up access
control lists as the
user of the bucket where
you store your data.
And we can control
that on the fly.
It's really simple.
We also have this great
feature of scale.
We could start off with 10
bytes, 100 bytes, an empty
directory, whatever you want.
And you could scale up to four
gigabytes and beyond.
You don't have to ask anybody's
permission.
And if you're done with
the data storage,
you get rid of it.
You don't have to run out to
the store and buy more hard
drives and then be done
with them, now what?
So it gives you that flexibility
to keep your data
around in whatever
form you want.
It has a feature for us that's
extremely important.
And that's that it's fast.
Getting the data into the Google
Cloud Storage pretty
quick, that's amazing.
There's Google data centers all
over the world that will
help get that data in there.
But even better yet, once you
get into that cloud, all the
thing that you will do with it
afterwards, the latency with
inside is so low,
it's fantastic.
It really makes the job of
building all the tools that
come along later on so much
easier because you're not
waiting for your data to get
from the storage to your
processors.
OK, so now we've got
data stored.
That's great.
So what does it look like?
I'm going to show you something
that's a little
frightening here.
This is called NEMA.
And it's not just normal NEMA,
which is comma separated
value, or CSV, data.
This is actually armored,
binary six-bit data with
integers that are like three
bits long, and all sorts of
strange things.
It's really a pain.
I hope all can read exactly
what that says.
That says I'm a ship position
message type three.
And I'm at a latitude
and longitude.
Right got it?
I don't.
So we need some way to convert
this from the batch, which is
completely useless to us, to
something like a simple CSV
file where we can actually see
a column of latitudes and
longitudes.
And with that, we
have something
called Compute Engine.
And I've written a library
called libais that's a C++
library designed to do this
decoding really fast.
It's taken me years to
get this code going.
And I'm not going to go right
into the language just because
of the investment of time.
And what am I going to do?
Compute.
We're in this, where we have
Compute Engine and App Engine
and all these other
great tools.
App Engine seems like the
reasonable solution, but it
doesn't support C++.
Well now, with Compute Engine,
we have the ability to use
generic Linux instances where
I can put whatever I want.
And I'm a control freak so I
get to put my software on
there and control it
the way I want.
That's awesome.
But if I had another language--
say I love R or I
love Pearl or Python or
Ruby, Go, Fortran--
whatever you like,
put it on there.
Run it your way.
It's great.
And on top of that, when you
build a Google Compute Engine
instance, it comes with these
things called surface accounts
that are OAuth 2.
I always get confused between
often it's OAuth
and it's OAuth 2.
These surface accounts already
have this authentication built
in, so your instance is already
available to get the
data that you gave it
permission for.
There's no fiddling around.
It's really quick.
So we're running this
libais code.
It parses all this wonky-looking
data.
And we get out something that
looks a little more
manageable.
Here's a quick table of decoding
that same very
message that's right above.
We have this thing called MMSI,
that's our ship ID number.
Navigation status,
are we sailing?
It's just an integer you
map into a table.
ROT, what's that?
Well that's Rate Of Turn.
It's whether the ship's going
left, right, straight.
We have SOG, Speed
Over Ground.
Longitude, Latitude, Course
Over Ground, which is the
direction the ship is moving.
And True Heading, which is
the way it's pointed.
So sometimes ships have to point
into the wind to go the
direction they want.
So, great.
We got some data decoded.
And let's take a look at what
it's like to create one of
these instances.
So I record a little video
of firing up an instance.
And for me, I like to
create a little--
going into Linux
image on there.
I've created an image out in the
world that's going to have
all my code.
It's ready to talk to all
the services I want.
It's going to load data from the
place I want, put it where
it's supposed to go, take
care of all of that.
So here I'm using at the gcutil
instance to add a new
instance in there.
Telling it which Linux
instance I've
created, where is it?
Go find it.
And let's fire up a
virtual machine.
And this is great.
You can control however
many you want.
You can start them.
You can stop them.
And it goes pretty quick.
It's less than about a minute
and a half for this particular
instance to get going from "I
want it" to "It's running and
I can access SSH into it".
I think it's pretty fantastic.
All right, so we've got data
and we're moving it around.
But we have a problem.
So data comes in from
our sensors.
We have a little script that's
running out on our sensors.
It's using buckets stores API
to load that into a Google
Cloud Store bucket.
And then we want to run
Compute Engine on it.
But how do we know to
get that data there?
Well, there's a new feature
out called Bucket
Notifications and you can tell
the infrastructure at Google
that, hey, when somebody puts a
file in that bucket, I want
to know about it.
Let me know.
And you'll hear later on a
little bit more about how
that's done with App Engine to
get those things registered
and to do something with it.
But what we do is we take those
notifications and turn
them into a task queue entry.
And what we do is look this
queue of things that we would
like to process and then I can
fire any number of instances
that I want I could stagger them
around the globe in each
of our data centers that you
could split off into, built
myself a load balancing system
however I feel like, and just
let those instances reach into
that queue and take the next
one off and lease
it for awhile.
And if they die, the
lease will expire.
The data goes back into
the task queue.
And some other instance
will pick it up.
It gives them the ability
to control that.
So even better, when I'm done
with the data, I write it back
into a bucket and I
forget about it.
I don't have to do anything.
I'm in a computer
engine world.
I can ignore everybody else.
As long as I'm writing
my CSVs into the
bucket store, I'm done.
And I get to hand
off to Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Thank you.
OK.
So now we have this very
big amount of data.
I want to serve it.
So you could imagine, we
have it as CSV files.
So you could imagine writing
something that will parse all
the CSV and imagine that we
want to get the latest
positions for all the ships.
Well, that's easy to write but
you have to run it yourself.
There's probably a better
way to do it.
Well we can put all that
data in Big Query.
So the advantage of BigQuery
is that it allows you to
crunch a huge amount of
data in a little time.
So it's not hours or minutes.
It's really seconds.
I'll do a little demo.
And the important part of this
is that having queries running
that fast allows you to iterate
very fast and really
find which queries give you back
interacting information.
So first, we have to load
that data into BigQuery.
And this is the way
we're doing it.
So we're using again bucket
notifications.
So when a Compute Engine
instance finishes processing
one file and creates this new
file with CSV data into the
bucket, we get a notification.
So it will be a post-request
on App Engine.
And App Engine will request
BigQuery to load that file.
So BigQuery and Cloud Storage
are related and actually
loading from Cloud Storage
is really fast.
So
OK now we have all the
data on BigQuery and
we could run queries.
So now we have this
table here.
It's 70 gigabytes,
which is a pretty
interesting amount of data.
And it's 374 [INAUDIBLE]
rows.
Every row represents a position
of a ship over time.
And if you go [INAUDIBLE].
So this is the table.
And we're going to be running
this little query here.
So what we're doing here
is a full scan range.
So we're going to get all
the rows in the table.
And we're going to compute the
average position for every
hour, for every ship.
So this is a pretty big query.
Imagine how long it could take
to run this on your computer
or if it would run it.
And it's a demo, so--
oh, there you go.
Six seconds.
Interestingly, we saw that
there were 70 gigabytes.
And here, we see the process.
There's only 14.
That's actually what
you're paying for.
And that's actually the
amount of data that we
got from the data.
Because we then get
all the columns.
So that can be also very
important for you.
So, just in case.
OK.
Now let's see how to actually
get that data from BigQuery
into the browser.
The first solution could be what
we saw before, that heat
map that is actually
you have--
well, we have App Engine
just serving some html.
Inside of that html, there's
some JavaScript.
And that JavaScript is actually
querying BigQuery directly.
This is nice because
it's easy to do.
And you can get a prototype
really fast.
But as you saw, it's
fast to write it.
Not fast to run it.
So we have to improve that.
That is not really enough.
So what if actually all the
queries go to App Engine?
So we serve the page.
But actually JavaScript
is now querying
our App Engine instance.
And then we can serve
from BigQuery.
Well, this doesn't
change anything.
This is actually making it even
slower, because now we
have two queries.
But we can add things
on top of this.
So the first thing we can do is
those BigQuery queries that
take normally tens of seconds,
we can actually store the
results of those queries
into our data storage.
Once we have it there, next
time, instead of reading again
from BigQuery, we'll read
from Datastore.
So now we've passed actually
from tens of seconds to some
seconds, which is nice,
but not good enough.
So what if we also
add Memcache?
Now what we're doing
is we read from
Datastore or from BigQuery.
But once we have this result
ready that is already
formatted either in binary
code or JSON.
Once we have it ready, we store
that into Memcache.
Now, the second request, we'll
just get that from Memcache
directly and serve it.
So we passed from tens of
seconds to seconds to hundreds
of milliseconds.
So this is pretty amazing.
And it allows us to actually
have an application that is
really fast and is really
interactive.
So from the html part, just
you open the webpage.
And before you can see the page,
you actually already
loaded all the data in it.
So we implemented this in Go.
Why?
Well, because it's very fast.
And it's very fast because it's
compiled to a binary code
into the App Engine servers.
And this means two things.
First, that it's running binary
code, which is, in
general, faster.
And also that it creates
only one binary.
And when you have to start a new
instance, you have to load
just one binary.
That's it.
That makes it orders of
magnitude faster than other
primary languages.
So this is actually a very
good thing to have.
Also, it's more efficient in
memory side, which allows you
to have less instances and also
more affordable instances.
You don't need a huge amount
of RAM to run your jobs.
And finally, it makes
concurrency very easy.
And why is Concurrency
important?
Well concurrency, when you're
running on the Cloud, is
actually something that you
should be thinking about
because most of the time on the
Cloud, you're waiting for
something to happen.
While you're waiting for
something to happen, it could
be nice to be doing something
else at the same time.
So let's see a little bit of
an example what I mean by
saying that Google
makes it easy to
write concurrent programs.
So we have these
lines of code.
Very simple things.
We're just creating a
Memcache item and
putting into Memcache.
Very simple.
Now imagine that this actually
takes too long.
And this is actually something
that we do at
the end of the request.
So imagine that these days, ten
seconds, we're actually
waiting for that before
we answer to the user.
That's not something
nice to have.
What if we want our user to have
an answer in less than
one second?
Well, we can write the different
[INAUDIBLE].
Now we're not waiting for it
at all, which is not good
either, because as soon as we
finish our request, this
Memcache set operation
probably will be
discarded and never run.
So we actually have to wait
for it, but not too much.
So now we waiting
for it again.
What we're doing is we're
using these channels.
So channels are a way to make
different go betweens
communicate between them.
So what we're doing is trying
to do our Memcache set
operation in a different
go between.
And our main go between
Is actually
waiting for it to finish.
So we have the same as before.
We could wait for too long.
But now we can use the
static statement.
And this will actually choose
between two different things.
Either the Memcache set
operation finishes--
in that case, we're good--
or one second passes.
This means and now, if Memcache
is working perfectly,
we don't have a problem.
We finish our version and
then we send a reply.
But if for some reason Memcache
is down, which never
happens, of course, we will
actually wait for only one
second and just keep
on doing our work.
If you want to know more about
Go, there's all these three
talks this afternoon.
They're really good and all
the speakers are somewhere
around there.
And tomorrow also we're going
to be the [INAUDIBLE]
of our network programming.
We're going to build
a peer-to-peer
network, very cool.
And if you have any questions,
the Office Hours
are also very useful.
And now for the rest of the
talk, back to Mano.
MANO MARKS: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
Thanks.
MANO MARKS: So now we're back
to visualizing data.
So once we've gotten this
data we're using
the Google Maps API.
And the reason we use a Google
Maps API is because it gives
us both a global and
a local context.
I can take a look at this
position viewer and I can see
where everything is on
this global scale.
But I can also zoom in and see
interesting things on the
local scale.
And I can switch over and take a
look at satellite imagery or
anything else that might
give the context as to
what's in the area.
And also it's super fast
and easy to use.
I want to show you a
couple other demos.
This is the San Francisco
office that Michael
Manoochehri--
he's collected this data.
This is a snapshot of that data
from, I think, just a few
days' worth of that data.
And it's just--
it provides this really--
look at that right there.
What's that?
That's a circle.
Well it turns out that--
I had to ask Kurt about this--
it turns out that ships will
anchor there.
And then they'll rotate around
the anchor because of current.
And you can actually see that
it's not perfectly uniform
because you don't see position
points at every single point
along that line.
So it's really interesting.
And WebGL gives us a way to
do some really beautiful
animations.
I'm just going to reload
this one here.
This is another one that
we can use to show some
interesting stories.
You don't see anything yet.
Don't worry about that.
What we wanted to do is take a
look at ships that they had--
we have lots of data
for the ships.
That we had over a certain
number of days--
I think it was 30 days-- we had
some interesting data so
we could show the paths that
they took around the globe.
And you start to slowly see
them come in, because of
course we're looking at
large amounts of data.
But we're starting--
we're showing the paths
grow over time.
And dynamically interacting
with this data by choosing
when to load and how to the
slide that data around.
And this gives us a really
interesting and rich
environment to explore
the data.
So you can take a look, for
instance, different line
segments are colored
differently.
And by a different
line segments, I
mean of the same path.
And what that tells us is how
old the position reports that
we have are for them.
So you can see, if you're
looking at an individual path,
you could see where it started
and basically what direction
it was going just from
these paths.
And we also get some interesting
stories here.
So this is Iceland.
It looks like there's
a lot a looping
around going on in Iceland.
But it's at the also people
coming from other places.
And it turns out that these are
fishing vessels that are
traveling around Iceland and
then going back to their home
ports doing fishing
in that area.
So we're really able
to very dynamically
interact with this data.
And you can also see places
where we have data that
doesn't look so good.
This is a great way to explore
the data because you'll see
here you've got ships
going over ground.
Well part of that is that we
only get the ships' locations
at certain times because
the satellite's
circling the earth.
So we may see it in one point
on one day and at another
point on another and that might
just happen to go over
ground so we're going to draw
a line in between it.
And sometimes you'll see really
drastic data going over
areas that are actually
much larger.
And that's sometimes areas in
which we can get some bad
data, as in transceivers that
are broadcasting incorrect
locations or incorrect IDs.
And you can tell other
interesting stories.
So look here on the coast off
of Somalia, well known as a
place where lots of
pirates hang out.
Look, we don't have any
ships the going there.
Or they're turning off their
broadcasters to not let you
know what their locations are.
And you can see that
again in the
position-oriented ones, as well.
So you can see here,
again, we have this
empty space right here.
Whereas, if you look on the
other side of Africa, you get
a very rich environment
of travel.
Lots of people going in in lots
of different directions.
I also want to point out that
the Google Maps API is
multi-platform.
So we've been showing you
JavaScript and WebGL.
But there's also iOS and Android
platforms which you
can use this Google Maps
on and then use
a Google data web.
And again, just to reiterate
something that Kurt said is,
we're not just interested
in ships.
We just--
well, Kurt is.
[LAUGHTER]
MANO MARKS: But the technology
can be-- this kind of
technology can be used for
any kind of sensor data.
Flights, taxi car services,
trucks, anything that you
really want.
Anything that's got a position
you can visualize on a map.
And the Google Cloud allows
you to easily do that.
So if you want to find out
more, there's links:
developers.google.com
and goland.org.
And that's all.
We will take questions now.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You have all this great
anonymous location data of
users Have you that of taking
all of that and seeing if you
can watch traffic flow of
all the Android users?
MANO MARKS: You do.
That's our traffic layer.
AUDIENCE: Well, yes.
But the individuals moving
around the world and how they
move, like day-to-day, have
you ever visualized all of
them, not just driving, but--
MANO MARKS: That a really
interesting question.
And I'm sure a lot of data
scientists would be really
excited about that.
And of course privacy folks get
really concerned when you
start talking about that.
So we couldn't talk about--
we don't have anything like
that that we can show you.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: I just want to know
how you're rendering that many
points at once in the
JavaScript API.
MANO MARKS: So we're using a
WebGL utility library called
canvas layer that actually syncs
a WebGL canvas on top of
the map and allows the
translation between WebGL
coordinates and latitude,
longitude.
AUDIENCE: So were you serving
that many points into the
browser and then this--
MANO MARKS: All those points
are being served into the
browser and then rendered
in the browser by WebGL.
We're not serving out
tile overlays.
That what allows for
the interactivity.
Brendan Kenny's session this
morning goes into a lot
greater depth on how that
was accomplished.
AUDIENCE: This is actually
somewhat connected to that
previous question.
How many data points are you
able to scalably show in the
browser window?
MANO MARKS: So in this case,
we're typically working with
tens of thousands.
But when you see the tracks,
each one of those is actually
being rendered as lines--
millions of vertices, basically,
are being processed
at that point.
And for point data, we've done
experiments where we've shown
one to two million rendering
pretty easily.
The major problem, then, as
we've discussed here, is the
communication between the
browser and the server to
actually get the data in.
In the back.
AUDIENCE: Is there any thought
to providing electronic
charting data similar to Google
Maps for the water?
Or an ECTISP-like situation?
KURT SCHWEHR: Sure.
Actually, if you use the GDL
open source tools, you can
take any-- it's called as S-57,
is the current format.
There's a new one
coming out so.
You can do that yourself.
There's several companies that
provide that kind of service.
Unfortunately, the United States
is the only country
that gives those out for free.
And if you get them from
anybody other than the
official provider, which we are
not, you're not allowed to
use them for navigation.
So when it comes to things
like ECTISP--
that's the standard for what
goes on your bridge of your
ship, for those who
don't know--
we can't play in that world.
Sorry.
You can, though.
MANO MARKS: Next question.
AUDIENCE: This is more of a
code question about the Go
stuff and the channel stuff.
So in the scenario that you
demoed earlier in the code
snippet, so when you try to
retrieve, it's like it'll try
to get it from Memcache.
And then if it takes more
than one second, just
respond to the user.
So I guess, in that scenario,
is it pretty much like
asynchronous processes happening
at the same time
where you're trying to fetch the
data the Datastore and if
Memcached fails, it just goes
from the Datastore.
Is that how it works?
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
I'm not doing that.
I'm trying to fetch-- so I'm not
waiting for the Git from
Memcache, because it's
really fast.
If it's not there, it just
answers, missed cache.
And then you get it
from Datastore.
And if you get it from Datastore
and it takes too
long, actually there's already
a time out of five seconds.
So after those five seconds
[INAUDIBLE], And then you
should be able to get that
data from BigQuery.
But as I saying before,
it's way slower.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY FLORES:
No problem.
MANO MARKS: Alright.
Well thank you very much for
coming and we'll be in the
Google Maps Sandbox immediately
after the session.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]